So in order to make this a little more concrete,
which might help you understand what I mean.
I'm going to show you some actual example from some code that you've actually
been running already in this lesson, maybe without even knowing it.
So think back to the first couple of
lessons where we were learning about supervised classification algorithms and
we were trying to identify emails by their authors.
Now, what I wanted you to do was to focus on the naive base classifier or
the SVM or whatever and just leave the pre-processing to me.
I would take care of, of reading in the emails and
getting them into a format that was good for you.
Now what I'm doing is I'm taking you into the code where I
actually did that pre-processing step.
So that you can see that there's, there's really no black magic there.
And that you would be able to do this completely on your own in the future.
Let me take you into that code and show you what I'm doing.
So I load in the data.
I put it in my TfidfVectorizer, which you're very familiar with by now.
And then there's another step right here.
Select percentile.
I make a selector and I select a percentile.
And what this step actually does, is it gets rid of a lot of the features.
I know that this is text data.
And that it's going to have thousands or perhaps tens of
thousands of features because of just the large vocabularies that we have.
And I also know that a lot of those words are going to be irrelevant.
So stop words is one example of irrelevant words.
But there's probably a lot of words in there that aren't stop words, but
still just don't have a lot of information in them.
They're not going to help me figure out who the author is very well.
And so what I've done here in this step, where I select a percentile,
is I actually say, get rid of a bunch of the features.
You go in and figure out for each feature individually how good of a job that
feature does at telling you the two people's emails apart from each other.
And only accept the best 10% of the features for
me to then use in my classifier.
So what I've done here is I've kind of sliced off that very top layer.
The features that seem to have the most information.
And I'm focusing on those when I make my classifier.
Now there's one other place where I did some feature reduction as well.
And you might not always want to mix these two together.
But I want to send you on a little bit of a treasure hunt to find it.
So I've told you about select percentile.
This is something that's available to me in
the sklearn.feature_selection module.
But there's also some feature selection that I can get
when I'm performing the TfidfVectorization of my data.
When I'm actually taking the words in my corpus and
putting them into my Tfidf matrix.
So what I want you to do is look up the documentation for this function,
the TfidfVectorizer.
And take a look at the arguments that I'm passing to it.
One of these arguments does something kind of interesting.
It says that if there's a word that's quite frequent,
that's something that we want to ignore as well.
By quite frequent, what I mean is that it occurs in many of the documents.
So for example, if you have a word that occurs in every single document, there's
an argument in here that will actually remove it while you're making your Tfidf.
So this is a little of a tricky quiz,
because I haven't told you exactly which argument is doing this.
Although a quick Google and
the sklearn documentation should make it pretty clear.
But the question that I'll ask you in the quiz is what this threshold is, for
this particular Tfidf to ignore the word.
So, does a word get tossed out,
if it occurs in 10% of the documents, 50% or 90%?